prudent le maire fait ce qu'il souhaite
je crois qu'il a été même élu député
sous l'étiquette la république en marche
et donc extrêmement cohérent
personnellement moi j'ai toujours
adhérent des républicains et je souhaite
que ça marche je souhaite étant la
majorité du président sous l'autorité
d'un premier lit ce qui s'appelle
edouard philippe
ensuite nous verrons bien ce qui se
passe moi j'ai pris l'habitude de ne pas
critiquer mes amis y compris ceux qui
ont pas fait de choix de supporter
l'intérêt général moi je suis très
heureux très fier de la politique que
nous menons et je suis très heureux et
très fier de le faire peut-être en
bousculant les clivages partisans